I went with a couple of my friends to
see this movie tonight when the end
credits came up we just sat there
speechless for about one minute
I love gone girl is directed by David
Fincher and stars Ben Affleck and
Rosamund Pike and this movie is about a
guy whose wife goes missing the mystery
surrounding that the press and the
media's view of him was he involved was
he not involved what happened to this
girl and where is she now if you guys
haven't been paying attention I have
been reviewing all of David Fincher's
previous work on my channel I skipped
alien 3 because Fincher himself doesn't
view that as his film I hope you guys
enjoyed those reviews and if you haven't
seen him yet please go check them out
they're all on my channel right now I
was really excited about this movie
because David Fincher is one of my
favorite directors working today I mean
he will have an actor do the smallest
little miniscule thing like a hundred
times if you watch the zodiac making up
there's a shot where Jake Gyllenhaal
tosses a notebook onto a car seat he and
him do that one tiny little movement so
many times and that's what I love about
Fincher he's a perfectionist and one of
the reasons he hired Ben Affleck to play
the husband in this movie is because Ben
Affleck himself as a person has been
under intense media scrutiny and a lot
of public harassment for his entire life
so this role is perfect for him and he's
fantastic in this movie this is one of
Ben Affleck's best performances because
he's very subdued Rosamund Pike is also
excellent in this movie this is probably
the best work I've seen from her period
I loved gone girl and I want to talk to
you guys about some really specific
reasons as to why this movie affected me
so much for one the marketing campaign
the marketing campaign for this movie
was absolutely brilliant I barely knew
anything going into this movie
I actually know someone who works for
the company that handled all the
trailers for this movie directly with
David Fincher's involvement their entire
goal was to make people interested in
the movie without revealing a whole
bunch of random things that you don't
need to know until you sit there in that
theater and experience the movie for
yourself
Fincher cherishes the movie-going
experience and that is something that I
absolutely applaud thank you so much to
the marketing team for keeping so much
this movie a secret because as the film
progressed it continuously surprised me
it got darker and darker and meaner and
Men
naive coal to the point where my mouth
was dropped on a number of occasions and
that is one of the things about this
movie that really stuck with me when it
ended because it really makes you think
differently about the way we perceive
the media about the way we perceive the
news and about how we are able to make
ourselves think that something is
factual just because you read it on the
internet or we saw it on television it's
so easy to take someone that we've never
met and make them out to be something
that they're not
and that's something this movie explored
so well was how the news and the media
can affect the situation and everyone
just thinks that's what it is
it's true and you get to see the behind
the scenes of how a person's life can
literally crumble to the ground until
there's nothing left simply based off of
a few lies now if you watch my previous
Fincher reviews over the past few weeks
you will have heard me say a hundred
times this guy is an immaculate visual
director his frames are perfect and gone
girl is one of the best-looking films of
the year without a doubt what I love so
much about this movies there are so many
hidden facets to this story that I knew
nothing about that I won't spoil for
anyone because I want you to be able to
experience them as well just as I did
without knowing but the various twists
and turns of the story takes do not come
off as showy they come off as wow that
is a great screenplay Affleck and pike
are fantastic in this movie but there
are two casting choices that I was very
skeptical about when I walk into this
movie that of Tyler Perry and Neil
Patrick Harris I'm just gonna say this
right off the bat Tyler Perry was great
in this movie he was very very good
humungous surprise he plays Ben
Affleck's lawyer in the film
I thought he knocked it out of the park
finally he got a serious role that was
not in a grandma outfit that wasn't Alex
Cross and he did a good job with it that
being said Neil Patrick Harris stuck out
like a sore thumb in this movie in my
opinion I think he was completely
miscast unfortunately gratefully he was
not in the movie that much now I think
Neil Patrick Harris is very talented
gentlemen I have nothing against him I
just don't think he was the right actor
for the role that he got in this movie I
think he's a vastly talented comedian
and performer but in this very intense
dramatic role that he's given as this
guy who
s's / Rosamund Pike since high school
didn't really work for me besides that I
think this is one of the best movies of
the year it's a story that is so dark
and rude you see the truth and a lot of
the things that are portrayed in this
movie you know that things like this
happen every day and that is what is so
shocking about it so I'm gonna start
doing this and you guys should too next
time you see a headline on the news or
on the internet or wherever take it with
a grain of salt because you never quite
know what's going on behind the scenes
I'm gonna give gone girl in a simply
because that one particular character I
thought was completely miscast that
being said it's a small nitpick in an
otherwise flawless feature I love this
movie definitely check it out it sneaks
up on you it is dramatically powerful
it's wonderfully acted and it is damn
sad when you really start thinking about
it so guys I do hope you check out my
previous David Fincher reviews that are
on my channel and how does this movie
rank for you and his filmography of
greatness as always guys thank you so
much for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes